su primer viaje como presidente de
Brasil Lula lanza un mensaje el mundo
Brasil está de vuelta al escenario
mundial se trata de un viaje lleno de
simbolismos Porque tanto Lula como Joe
biden derrotaron en las urnas a
candidatos cercanos a la extrema derecha
además ambos tuvieron que lidiar desde
el inicio con acusaciones infundadas de
fraude electoral y con ataques
antidemocráticos se espera que a partir
de ahora las relaciones entre los dos
países mejoren recordamos que el ex
presidente Jair bolsonaro demoró seis
semanas en reconocer la victoria de
biden se hablará de muchos asuntos en
esta Cumbre bilateral de seguridad
alimentaria por supuesto de cambio
climático de igualdad racial pero
también de control de las migraciones
Lula viaja acompañado de una amplia
comitiva de ministros con personajes
emblemáticos como la ministra de medio
ambiente Marina Silva y la de igualdad
racial aniel y Franco además es posible
que Estados Unidos anuncie que va a
inyectar dinero en el fondo amazonía
creado por Alemania y Noruega para
ayudar a proteger el mayor bosque
tropical del mundo